good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen um this is the
council's first virtual meeting
um and everybody's asked to adhere to
the etiquette for virtual meetings
as published on the council website
you will have been provided with a copy
of the council's etiquette four meetings
in advance this meeting
however to reiterate the main points
please ensure
your device is fully charged or
recharging
please move your microphones when not
speaking
please indicate in the chat bar if you
wish to speak
when invited to address the committee
please ensure
your microphone is switched on and
switched off immediately once you've
finished
please ensure that you've switched off
or to silent any other devices you may
have
that may interrupt the proceedings
if any member encounters i.t problems
causing them to drop out of the virtual
meeting
they should use best endeavors to rejoin
as quickly as possible
should the member be unable to rejoin
the meeting they will be deemed to have
left the meeting at that point
and the meeting will continue
numbers to call should you experience
any it problems
are the it help desk oh one seven
eight nine two 260020
or caroline nash the democratic services
manager
on 079 76
416 3
and can i remind members that this
meeting is being broadcast
live and that members of the public
are able to view the proceedings in real
time
thank you
to start the meeting i call on my
chaplain the reverend nikki chaston
to open our proceedings
thank you can you just confirm that you
can hear me talking
i i can hear you nikki thank you
thank you we start our prayers by
thinking and remembering those who
sustain
our nation heavenly father thank you for
those who work
whose work sustains our nation and the
country in which we live
all those who continued to work during
the pandemic lockdown
so that the rest of us could live safely
and comfortably
in our homes for those who grow
and provide our food or who through
industry commerce and transport make it
available
we thank you for those who day and night
maintain the public services
and amenities for the police and for
those who respond to emergencies
we ask you to teach us to remember that
all our lives depend upon the work of
many minds and hands
and we pray that we may live thankfully
and immunity
as members of one human family
amen
hello yes thank you nikki
very much um i do have other prayers as
well if you'd like me to continue
to continue to keep carry on thank you
globally the rapid spread of the
coronavirus has demonstrated
how the health and well-being of just
one of us has implications for all and
we give thanks for all those whose
work in health healing and social care
and medical research has sustained us
during this difficult time and we
commend lord to your loving care
the souls of those who died as a result
of the coronavirus
and ask you to comfort those who mourn
their loss
and internationally as our thoughts and
concerns have been dominated by
pandemics and its effect on our
communities
we do not forget the other atrocities
that plague our world
we remember the serenity massacre in
bosnia in 25 years ago
grant oh god that your holy and
life-giving spirit
may so move every human heart and
especially the
hearts of the people of this land the
barriers which divide us may crumble
suspicions disappear and hatred cease
that our divisions will be healed we may
live
in justice and peace amen
and life has changed this radically
but this crisis amazingly has revealed
some of the best
of humanity thank you heavenly father
for a simple act of kindness
when human love reaches out
towards human need with gratitude where
we
remember and give thanks for all those
who during the lockdown looked outside
and
instead of inside themselves who helped
their local communities
in times of need
on them and we sadly
remember neville beamer
as we gather to remember before god
neville
a former member of this council heavenly
father
neville was a good friend colleague and
gentleman
concern was always for others we give
thanks for his contribution during this
time in office and for all
that he did for this community and
individuals within it
both as a council member and in his role
as a vicar
we pray for sheila his family friends
and all who mourn his death
we ask that you give them your comfort
strength and confidence in the promise
of eternal life amen
amen thank you
thank you nikki for those words um
we now move on to point one of the
agenda
which is attendance and apologies for
absence
i call upon the head of paid service to
report
and take a roll call of attendance and
no topologies for absence
of this meeting councillors by
confirming you are present
you you are also confirming and please
state
that you can hear and see the
proceedings
mr buckland thank you chairman as
sherman said when i call your name i
appreciate it if you just briefly
introduce yourself please and confirm
that you can hear and see the
proceedings
um chairman of council councillor kettle
council the kettle i can see and hear
the proceedings
thank you councillor dixon
council tony dixon sorry sorry uh
thank you councillor victoria orcock i
can see and hear all proceedings
thank you kevlar parker
counter slobarka i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor cargill council
cargill i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor cleve councillor
cleve here i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor crump thanks to the
crump i can hear and see the proceedings
thank you councillor curtis
kelsey curtis here i can hear and see
the proceedings thank you
counselor
counselor i can see and hear proceedings
thank you casper fielding you are
slightly muted but we did hear you thank
you
like a tesla
good afternoon it's councillor edward
fitter and i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor fleming
uh councillor fleming i can see and hear
clearly thank you
thank you i'm the castle
uh hello councillor yeah i can see and
hear the proceedings thanks
thank you that's the foreman councillor
foreman
here i can see and hear the proceedings
councillor ian fradley i can see and
hear the proceedings
thank you councillor jenny tragery now
so jenny fragile i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you harris good afternoon everyone
councillor harris i can hear and see all
the proceedings
councillor harvey council harvey can see
and hear all proceedings
seraphine councillor henshaws i can see
and hear
the proceedings
councillor jefferson i can hear and see
the proceedings
thank
here i can hear and see the proceedings
thank you councilman
mills
here i can see and hear the thank you
councillor
proceedings
good afternoon everybody councillor
parry i can hear and see
all the proceedings thank you councillor
potoguella
okay we'll come back in a minute
councillor richards
councillor richards i can see and hear
all proceedings
thank you castle riley
good afternoon councillor riley i can
see and hear the proceedings
thank you rock councillor rock
i can see and hear proceedings thank you
rolf councillor rolfe i can see
and hear all proceedings thank you mr
shenton
councillor shenton i can in here all
proceedings
thank you and councillor wally huggins
councillor wally hoggins i can see and
hear all proceedings
thank you i will return councillor gayla
are you are you there
yes can you hear me we can hear you now
can you yeah
so present i can see and hear the
proceedings although the
the connection is not that great okay
we've got you now um chairman also we've
received apologies from councillors adam
bromage and kendall thank you
so thank you mr buckland
and we are joined as well by members of
your portfolio
yourself once you mr buckland mr grafton
mr weeks and mr platt
is that correct
that's great judy lewis as well
thank you um i therefore move on to
point two of the
gender which is disclosures of interest
um and i would like uh if any member who
has
an interest in any item on the agenda
please could you now
just disclose it please
right i think i've got no record
of anybody contacting you by the chat
function
um you have had written notification
from councillor rock
that he has an interest in eyes in
one item on the agenda this
comes to what would you like just to
disclose your
interest please mr chairman
uh i have an interest in item 13 which
includes a reference in the appendix to
improving
health access to health services in
southern
and are declaring interest in that i am
the vice chairman of a patient
participation group
thank you council rock um i am just
uh i've noticed um council pemberton
um can you just confirm that you can see
and hear the proceedings please
yes chairman i wasn't sure whether it
was something i'd said as far as the
chief executive
was concerned but despite his best
efforts councillor pemberton is here
and councillor pemberton can see and
hear the proceedings
thank you council pemberton sorry
chairman
just just a moment of worry if we'd
missed you outside pemberton
um we now move on to um item three of
the agenda which are the minutes
um firstly i'd like to record
that um in the minutes 24th of february
2020
in response to question six the the
leader refers to a meeting with nadim's
a highway that
took place in january 2021
this should be of course january 2020
so that will be amended um
in inside minutes does anybody have
any other comments they wish to make on
it on the minutes of those three
meetings perhaps if i start off with the
first one
which was our last full council meeting
in february
does anybody wish to raise any points on
those minutes
uh cancer or [ __ ] you've got a question
yes thank you um i just did comment
that uh i'm down twice as apologies
right we will without that will be
corrected thank you council
[ __ ] um if there are no
other comments on the 24th of february
if anybody has an objection to those
minutes
please record it in the chat function
now
other than the amendments that have just
been mentioned to the date and counselor
or cox record
i've got no record coming through of any
amendments
other than those therefore i'm going to
assume
that as councillors you are happy with
the minutes of the 24th of february
thank you we then move on to the minutes
26th of march
now for those of you who recall this was
a uh extraordinary meeting set up to
deal with the immediate impact of the
outbreak of
um covered 19 and the
lockdown announced by the prime minister
a few days beforehand
therefore the the minimum
core number of councillors was invited
to match the political balance of the
council at that time
those councils not invited
were not treated as being absence and
now their
um apologies were not required as they
were not invited that meeting although
it was a meeting of the council
the minutes now reflect that so
for those who attended that meeting on
the 26th of march
can i confirm um
that anybody
that everybody's happy who attended the
meeting that those minutes are an
accurate reflection of the meeting on
the 26th of march
right there are no
problems uh there are no identified
issues with that
uh again i move on to 27th of may
meeting
uh can we please confirm uh if there are
any amendments people wish to make to
the 27th of
may meeting which again was held under
the lockdown
provisions with the minimum court number
being invited to that meeting
again the minutes record that those who
were not invited were not being treated
as absent from that meeting
okay i've got no record in the chat
function
of anybody uh having any concerns
and therefore i will accept those
minutes for a correct record our new
counselor councillor pataguella
has wished me just to note that she was
not a member of the council
for any of those three meetings thank
you
right and now move on to the
announcements
um because i've already welcomed you all
to this virtual meeting it's the very
first
virtual meeting stratfor district
council
[Music]
this is a new era in many respects
firstly um as is normal i'd like to
welcome our new member for welford
council manuela pataguela
um and at this stage i'll go on to
announce
my engagements have taken place
from mid-february obviously they're in
brief
and were contained materially
by the lockdown that started in march
however
i was able to attend uh the inaugural
meeting of coventry let
china business group um
i then attended the warwickshire
accounts
uh scout workshop county scouts group at
limited bar
the mayor of ulster civic dinner
an exhibition at compton verde
i attended the bear pit theater and i
attended stratford choral society at
holy trinity
stratford
worryingly the last
four events were on the four consecutive
nights
up to lockground lockdown but so far so
good
subsequent lockdown i was grateful
in the absence of the many celebrations
planned across the district
uh to commemorate ve day on behalf of
the council
with a video recording organized by
beverly heming
and posted on our website it wasn't
quite what we imagined would be doing on
v day
but i think it was important to record
that memorable event
let us hope the vga day is a little bit
more um relaxed
18 months ago we commemorated the 100th
anniversary of the war to end all wars
and yet this war this year we
commemorated the 17th
75th anniversary of that european
armistice
that's really what i was saying in that
presentation
um let us hope
that things can move better going
forward
it's been a momentous four months not
only for each one of us personally
but our residents whom we represent the
officers and staff of this council
and the council itself notwithstanding
all those other parties for whom we work
i'm sure we all recognize the huge
contribution
at great great and considerable personal
risk
of the doctors nurses porters and
ancillary staff
of the nhs and those who volunteered
their own services
as drivers porters or any other roles
during this crisis
i would like on behalf of all
councillors and if i may
the staff of this council should record
our thanks to those in the health
service
for what they have had to deliver during
this period
who could have imagined when we last met
the fire storm and revolution
that has swept through our district and
our county and in fact the entire globe
but within our own district we've seen
volunteers from every community
learning helplines shopping for
neighbors delivering food
i would like on behalf of all counselors
to thank all those who have tried to
make people's lives better
during these dark times i'm aware of
course that many councillors
have also been heavily involved in their
communities and their awards
i'm not going to name your names but you
all know
who who you all are and as chairman i'd
like to thank you for that contribution
to your communities
i in particular though i would like to
thank all the officers
and staff of this council
who have gone well beyond their remit
during the last four months
everyone have all had to learn
the new skill of working remotely thank
you
all for managing to do that so
successfully
but i would like to single out the
following groups who've gone beyond what
was expected of them
the order is not relevant
i'd like to start with the contact
center staff
who've been manning their phones from
7am to 7pm
in the peak time at elizabeth house not
working remotely
handling up to a thousand calls a day
from those
of our residents who are genuine and
very real worries
about money housing jobs and of course
health
for whom this council was their first
port of call
well done the environmental health team
particularly in the earlier stage of the
lockdown when compliance was not being
strictly adhered to
had a mammoth chart charge to educate
everyone in the district about the
importance of social distancing
and staying at home the homeless team
who had to pick up those who did not
have a home to go to
and find somewhere to accommodate them
during this very
very difficult time
the council's revenue team who have
managed to deliver nearly 40 million
pounds of funding
to businesses and residents across the
district
whether through the government funding
business rate support scheme
or the council tax hardship schemes
without the enormous effort of the itn
wow teams
we would not be here today and the
council's work
would have grown to a halt in march as
everybody went home
and as a service our residents require
we would have been helpless
finally those working in the food
distribution hub based in the stratford
leisure center
now for those of you who can't see the
screen i'm just going to read out the
names
of those people the entire contact
center staff
the entire environmental health team and
the homeless team
the new teams delivering the business
rates and hardship funds jenny love
steve bosworth liam morris
david good john solis claire kitchen
neil harrison clint beresford
michelle blundell michelle blackham
and supported by the rest of the
revenues team
in it james dealey
matt reading molly turvey
thomas venue sorry thomas venus
peter ireland
alex eden tim page natasha hall
and the rest of the it team
the wow team leila doman timururi
hannah heath and ollie schofield
and the team in the food distribution
hub
paul reed craig bourne serena james
caroline nash lucy wilkes adrian
blethoon
richard morgan graham raspin chris alden
allen tim beric evan gibson
simon gill olivia quill quinn
sorry olivia liz javorska mark humphries
phil franklin mark rogers and sam light
all your contributions have made
a huge difference
so all our residents and it enabled
everybody else to continue working
on their day jobs whilst we were looking
after those residents
in trouble the list is clearly not
complete
but i have asked members of the senior
management team to provide
those names it also excludes of course
those members of the senior management
team
led in particular by david platts and
robert weeks
and i'm sure there are others but thank
you on behalf of all members for what
you've done to save people and support
their jobs in their communities
i would like to congratulate david
buckland and the senior management team
that he leads for what collectively
stratford district council
has achieved david to your team
well done
in february and early march before the
uk crisis started
i was contacted by officials from the
chinese province the geography
and the city of fujo who asked me to
help them procure ppe
owing to their own severe shortages
there was no
spare ppe in the uk and i was unable to
help
despite that at the end of march the
city of frugal contacted me
to ask how they could help stratford
with our own ppe shortages
at that same time the city of maishan in
sichuan province who have a similar long
cultural heritage to rujo
had also contacted me to ask if
we needed support with ppe together
those two cities donated thirty five
thousand face masks
five thousand gloves and two hundred
theater guns
two strap for district council advised
by councillor barker
portfolio holder and in consultation
with
the southwestern foundation trust we
were able to deliver these items
directly to work hospital for use where
needed
by the nhs across southwestern
i personally thank the mayors of both
fuji and mai shang for these generous
donations to the district
i'd like to add that our consultant well
the person whom we speak to a lot in
london mr dean ding who
was able to help with this delivery has
personally delayed made a personal
donation to the district council
which is due to be delivered uh this
week
of ppe for officers and members for
their use as well
well thank you mr ding
moving on as we've heard from my
chaplain nikki early wrong
i would like to recognize not one but
two groups of victims
and i'm shortly going to ask that we
hold a minute silence
to reflect on the following
firstly the latest estimate shows there
have been 165 residents in the district
who've died from covert 19 along
with over 516 lab confirmed cases
there will be many more confirmed uh
unconfirmed cases there has been some
discussion about a
possible memorial but that is a
discussion for a later date
whilst we remember those who've died
from this ghastly disease
on a different turn and along with other
local authorities both in warwickshire
and across the country we've been asked
to recognize
that this month marks the 25th
anniversary of the most recent act of
mass genocide in europe
the slaughter of over 8 000 men and
women in srebrenica
we have said it before i hope we don't
have set again
but we must continue to learn lessons
and fight
the critical battles in our communities
caused by hate
prejudice and ignorance whatever our
political views
we must work together to build bridges
and let us remember the words of fellow
uk british politician joe cox
we are far more united and have far more
in common
than that which divides us
on behalf of victims
[Music]
of disease and prejudice and hate
ladies and gentlemen i'm now going to
call for a minute of silence
thank you ladies and gentlemen
i'm now going to call on our leader
councillor jefferson
um who i think personally has not left
his office
for the past three months despite
allegedly booking a week's holiday
um council jefferson would you like to
give me or give us your announcements
thank you
thank you cheers
hello
it's been uh very strange and
a very very busy time we've had to
change the way we work
there is no doubt about it that we've
had the senior management
team and indeed all officers and cabinet
in particular
working very closely together and i
think that's been extremely effective
and the benefits have been clear
it has been a very stressful time
the pressure's been remorseless the
number of meetings we've had has gone up
tremendously i would actually like to
echo the chair
and place on record i think everyone at
stratford district council
has responded magnificently to
unprecedented challenges
i think it's been a really great effort
by everyone uh one of the new things
we've had to do
is put a great deal of effort into
lobbying both about our council's
financial position
which is dire and about the impact of
kovid 19 on the district
noticeably its impact on tourism
i'm told that the message that we are
the fourth hardest hit district
has been heard loud and clear
we've had meetings and i've had meetings
with
our mps bays i was invited to a meeting
of councils heavily impacted
by the decline in tourism and that
meeting included york
bath bournemouth brighton and liverpool
as well as myself
noticeable we were the smallest town
there
i've used regular meetings with
warwickshire county council
commenting warwickshire lep and the
west midlands combined authority to
continue making the points about how
heavily we've been impacted we submitted
a proposal for funding for the riverside
corridor project
and it's a tribute to officers that that
was turned around in two and a half
working days
it actually reinforces the point i made
earlier
about the speed at which we've had to
work
compared to previously where meetings of
the
lap and the wmca were monthly
there have been weekly meetings now for
both the lep
and the wmca economic recovery group
these provide a really good platform
for our lobbying efforts but i do have
to say
the reports from the businesses at these
meetings indicate
that i think recovery will be slower
than many commentators expect
we're working closely with shakespeare's
england the lep
birthplace trust and the rsc on creating
an offer and ask for
arts and heritage in stratford this
recognizes the significance of the
birthplace trust in the rsc
to our local recovery i would also
add shakespeare's england has been an
invaluable source of background data
to support our lobbying efforts we'll
also continue to work with the
university warwick on the wells born
campus development
i've also written letters to the dhclg
and base i even managed to get a
response
from the quotes head of ministerial
correspondence
which seemed to me to plumb new laws in
bland platitudes
letter writing appears to be the least
effective form of lobbying
and i would just like to add
i would like to take this opportunity to
welcome julie lewis to the council
and i think it is a perfect example of
the saying
timing is everything or perhaps not
welcome julie
thank you
[Music]
thank you council jefferson um i now
call on mr buckland head of paid service
uh for his comments please
thank you chairman and thank you leader
well i i first got to just like track
the very kind words that you said about
staff that they've acted phenomenally
over the last few months so so thank you
for your tributes to staff
i'd also like to pay tribute to
councillors and our communities because
collectively everybody's really stepped
up during this crisis so thank you all
for all your efforts across the district
over the last three or four months
um i was going to introduce julie but
but the lead has already done that um
so conscious of time chairman i i think
i'll move on but thank you very much
everybody
cheers
right we now move on to the next item on
the on the agenda
um which is item five
um in relation to membership with the
council uh former council
neville bemer um we've already heard
from nikki
um who worked with neville in
uh trinity stratford um
the councillor neville bieber who was he
was district councillor
of stratford and guild and hathaway ward
from 2007
to 2015 and chairman of the council from
2012 to 2013.
i'd now like to invite any member of the
council
and any full member of the council who
may be
listening uh to address the meeting if
they so wish
right uh council jefferson
thank you chair uh i knew neville for
about
15 years i was amazed at the depth of
his involvement with the community
he was always active and engaged
uh he was particularly passionate about
stratford football club
i found him to be an excellent sounding
board
all was willing to listen and offer sage
advice
i thought he was a very genuine very
nice man
and i think what was said earlier as
soon as he will a real gentleman
i'll miss him and i think stratford upon
evan will miss him as well
thank you chair
cancer fragility
uh thank you chair uh can you hear me
yes
um i first met uh neville when i was
first
elected way back in the early part of
this century
when we were co-counsellors in much
large
large awards there when there were three
of us representing a much larger ward
i've always found neville incredibly
supportive and
uh community-minded and we worked
extremely well together
particularly on um our planning issues
and we had some really
interesting planning issues to cope with
one of my best memories of neville is
however
in his other role as vicar i went with
my
uh son and grandsons to church one day
and he was giving the sermon abe is
supported by an extremely bad tempered
emu
making some of some particular points
and she was struggling
bit like roy had in the uh in the pulpit
with the with the blue feathers um
that's still being remembered by my
grandsons
and and my son always remember neville
as
quite a funny man as well as having his
very serious side
he will be missed
thank you chair
thank you very much uh councillor junior
fragile
as i should have made clear earlier on
um councillor donald
are you wishing to speak
yes please chair um so wonderful neville
beamer was one of the first people i met
when i joined stratfor conservatives
he was consistently incredibly kind and
as a fine
example of a compassionate conservative
um
he always found a calm and simple
solution if
conversations around a committee table
got heated
and always took everybody's point of
view into account
both neville and the wonderful sheila
ran a fascinating preschool group called
trinity tots
which one of my nieces attended and they
really did help her build her confidence
and they very kindly cast her as mary in
the nativity a plum role that none of us
in the family would ever have hoped to
have got
and we're all incredibly excited however
said nice
has and remains to have a very strong
independent mindset
and as she was due to walk up the islet
holy trinity in front of all the parents
to go and sit
in the stable stage set she announced at
the top of her lungs that she had no
intention of having a baby she didn't
want a baby
and didn't want to take part at which
point joseph did a runner
and meh lovely neville and wonderful
sheila
with their calm kindness had to sort the
situation out for everybody and we still
up past that to my loving niece today
who's now
in her first year at chottery we as a
family will deeply miss neville
his kindness his wisdom and his
compassion
thank you
thank thank you councillor o'donnell um
councilor mills you've indicated
councillor mills sorry thank you mr
chairman
um i really don't know what i can say uh
that's um not being said about neville
already but
um for me neville will always be in my
thoughts um
and as you know neville recommended that
i'd be his vice
chairman uh which led me to being
chairman
actually i'm not sure i've ever forgiven
for that but um
but uh if i went running to neville um
during my term of office uh for his
guidance and
he would always say chris you know don't
worry always be yourself
and not to feel self-important when
wearing that chain of office and i tried
not to be
um always remember my first uh time of
uh
being chairman of the full council
meeting again i sought his help
and the best tip he gave me was i could
always press the new
the mute button if um a member went on
too long or was being
um uh disruptive but
unfortunately i never had that pleasure
um when my mother
passed away um it was neville who got in
touch
to say that he'll be happy to uh to
to uh conduct the service for me and
which i of course jumped at the chance
um he was also a great consular
especially at that very difficult time
but um
i will always remember uh neville as a
true gentleman as people have said
before
um a great role model and uh a true
friend thank you mr chairman
thank you um council mills
um that will save my bacon um
when i decided that it would be
appropriate for us to
as a council um commemorate the 100th
anniversary of the end of the first
world war
um and for those of you recall we had a
service
outside elizabeth house
which i thought would be a relatively
simple um
exercise um and
uh progressively my chaplain nikki whom
we heard earlier on was unable to attend
each other
other commitments but she suggested i
speak to neville
um we'd worked together
on the council for one year um
but i've already seen him lead prayers
at council on a number of occasions
um the service
that i started off with a rough
background
um he turned into a proper service of
commemoration
of that anniversary uh he brought
everything that i hoped and wished for
to that service
which of course he was a chaplain of
robert schlugen i had a deep
understanding
of the importance of that ceremony
um so we put together a great service
and i'm delighted that i was able to ask
him for that
and um it will be a great regret
not to see him in the council chamber
again
uh or around stratford whether at the
holy trinity or the other
many other occasions that we used to see
him
as both a vicar um
a member of the community and of course
a sport of both the british legion
and stratfor football neville we will
miss you
as i'm sure uh your wife sheila
and all your family are also doing at
the moment
your passing was far far too early
and that is a deep regret our thoughts
are with
your wife sheila and your family
thank you neville
we therefore move on now
thank you for those comments we move on
therefore
to note the following
that the council notes with regret
the death of councillor neville bhima
district council councillor for the
stratford ward
and the hathaway award for the period 27
to 2015 and chairman of the council
of 2012-2013 and we extend
our sympathy to his family and friends
in their loss
if this was a normal meeting we'd go
through the roll call
but i'm sure i can uh i have the full
support of all councillors
in that uh proposal
thank you ladies and gentlemen
we therefore move on to point six which
is public participation
um and we have had no questions from the
public
uh and therefore can move on to point
seven
uh which is the political balance
this item is for noting only but i will
request that uh tony jefferson
introduces this item hi council
jefferson
thank you chair uh this political
balance calculation
reflects uh the fact that uh councillor
jackie harris is now a member of the
conservative group it's the usual
routine
arithmetic result so
if i need to can i propose that council
accept the revised political balance
calculation
chairman you're muted
all right thank you mr buckland uh does
anybody have any comments they wish to
make uh
on the political balance it is an item
for noting only
i'm getting many agrees coming through i
haven't got any people who wish to speak
on that item
and on that basis as we are only noting
it we'll move on to point
eight which is the electoral review
local government boundary commission for
england and again
i will invite eddie jefferson as leader
of the council to
introduce this item thank you chair
uh as the background to this in july
2019 uh the local government boundary
commission wrote to the council to say
that
based on electoral data there was some
imbalance of electors in some wards in
the district
and by minute 473 this councillors
agreed to
the proposed timetable for a further
electoral review
of its electoral arrangements
unfortunately the initial meeting fell
at the start of kobe 19
and was therefore postponed a virtual
meeting has since
taken place between the local government
boundary commission executive
myself and the chief exec and the head
of law and governance and the revised
time table
is actually attached as appendix
one i have to report that the meeting i
thought was extremely positive
and productive and can i therefore
recommend to council that
the timetable for the local government
boundary commission for
england be noted and that the audit and
standards committee
be requested to form an electoral review
working group to undertake the work
thank you chair
thank you council justin now does any
counsellor wish to speak on this item
um
right
i've got no requests to speak on this
item
um therefore we will need as this isn't
a gender item that he's voting on
um we do have to go through uh as we are
not physically present we have to go
through
a roll call of members and therefore
i'll call on
the head of paid the head of paid
service to
mr buckland to conduct a poll on this
item
uh mr buckland yeah check chairman
before we call the poll
although the leader of the council has
proposed the item can we hear a second
there as well please thank you thank you
mr
uh mr councillor shenzhen you've
confirmed you want to second this could
you
could you speak please yeah uh guess
it's councillor shenton i think we
should move ahead
to the vote on this i second this
proposal
thank you we therefore have a proposal
councillor jefferson and the second
council of shenzhen um and therefore
again going to ask the head of aid
service mr buckland to conduct the poll
on this item
thank you thank you chairman so in
conducting the polar again repeat every
councillor's name
um we're voting on the recommendation
which was shown on page 49 of your
agenda
if you could please indicate repeat your
name and then
suggest whether you're voting for
against what abstaining
recommendation has printed on page 49 um
councillor kettle
councillors kettle uh in favor
thank you council dixon councillor dixon
four thank you councillor
councillor thank you
councillor parker councillor barker four
thank you councillor cargill council
cargill four
thank you councillor cleve councillor
cleve
four thank you councilman anthony
for thank you
councillor tech four thank you
foreman councillor and four
they keep because like ian crutchley
councillor ian fragili four thank you
councillor jenny frenchley
council journey for actually four thank
you councillor harris
councillor harris for thank you harvey
council harvey
four thank you again for hencha seraphin
councillor henshaw seraphine four thank
you
jennifer jefferson councillor jefferson
four jennings
thank you councilman mills
councillor mills for thank you
councillor o'donnell
councillor o'donnell for councillor
harry
councillor parry for you mustn't forget
councillor pemberton
thank you for making me feel part of
this today chief executive councillor
pemberton
thank you all right councillor
pataguella councilor pertoguela four
thank you richards councillor richards
for
newcastle o'reilly councillor valley for
against the rock
hoggins councillor wally hoggins
four thank you chairman that was
unanimous support for that
recommendation thank you
thank you mr buckland i i therefore move
on to
item 9 of the agenda and this
relates to the development requirements
supplementary planning
document adoption part 5
climate change adaptation and mitigation
and i invite councillor darren pemberton
as deputy leader of the council to
introduce this item
thank you chairman uh just before i kick
off may i just add
my thanks as deputy leader to each and
every
one of our fabulous members of staff
for the great work that they've done
throughout all of this they have
they have really stepped up to the plate
and done a fantastic job and
really been very supportive for all of
us so just my thanks
to add to everybody else's so
council we are considering um the
development requirements a supplementary
planning document
and known as an sbd spd which is the
adoption of part
five climate change adaptation and
mitigation
um the background to this is that
arising out of the declaration of a
climate change emergency
uh one of the uh recommendations of the
climate change panel
was that we take um early steps to
provide further guidance to
our planning officers in relation to the
existing core strategies
in terms of ensuring that all new
developments
insofar as the core strategy allows
meets our climate change
aspirations and goals and that is the
purpose of this particular document
which
has been consulted upon has been
reviewed by the overview and scrutiny
committee at its meeting on the 10th of
june and has subsequently then been
considered by cabinet on the 6th of july
just very quickly before getting to the
recommendation i am
i would like to point out an element
particularly for
members of planning committee this
doesn't change the recommendation
but the part five of the spd does
include a climate change
checklist uh which applicants will be
required to complete
setting out the adaptation and
mitigation measures that their proposal
will incorporate
so therefore subject to adoption of part
five at council today
uh development management officers will
then have to undertake an
update to what is called the local list
and that will be subject to a six week
period of consultation
the the updated local list will
therefore be effective from
october the first 2020 um subject to
consideration of any consultation
responses
and it will be from that point onwards
that the submission of the climate
change checklist will be a formal
requirement
and so we do have to just uh just uh
finally sort of sign off the uh
the the and dot the eyes and cross the
t's on that
so members uh the recommendation to
council is that part five
climate change adaptation and mitigation
of the development requirements
supplementary planning document be
formally adopted and
i um i propose that recommendation
and look for a second uh thank you
thank you uh council pemberton uh do we
have a secondary
mr cargill councillor cargill you're
offering second the proposal
council cargill's second year proposal
thank you i now have a request to speak
from
councillor junit council junior would
you like to speak please
yes um i i would like to say an enormous
thank you
to uh all the officers that contributed
to making this spd happen
it came about as the result of the not
only the climate change motion
but the task and finish group that
resulted from that
and and the requirements do improve and
emphasize the importance of energy
efficiency
biodiversity and mitigation of flood
risk and
all are important and all are welcome
although i was disappointed that a
mandatory
requirement for renewable energy could
not be achieved i do understand the
legal issues that arose
after changes to government policy what
is really important
is that this spd will send a message
on the importance that this district
council gives
to addressing climate change uh and the
requirements that are expected from new
developments conversions
and changes of use and i hope that it
will also form
a sound basis for the course strategy
review
i feel that this is an important
achievement but it's only one piece of
the jigsaw of policies and actions
that will need to be undertaken if we
are to address the challenges of climate
change
and biodiversity loss it's the beginning
not the end
but thank you to everybody that has
contributed i do
hope that you will all pass this today
thank you councillor junit um councillor
rock you've raised the point that you
cannot see
proceedings but you've reassured us
via the chat function that you can hear
them
i think you wanted just to that to be
noted
uh that there does appear to be one or
two cancers who have
problems with the visual bit of the
audio visual
um after teams
uh and i can confirm i'm somewhat in the
same position as well
uh so that has been noted
uh i'll now move on to council virginia
foreign uh would you like to speak
please
thank you chair may i just say that i've
got problems uh
uh i've only got the initials on my
screen however i'd just like to
support very much what council junior
said and say going forward
i hope with the new iteration of the
core strategy
we will make sure that we try to cover
issues
like the um the the issue that we have
that we couldn't actually enforce this
time
we must make sure that we actually look
at the future
and try to make sure that we are
well supported in our course strategy
going forward
thank you
thank you councillor frankly
does anybody else wish to speak on this
item
um right i have no messages coming
through on the chat function
uh indicating anybody wishes to speak we
have the proposal
um from council hamilton
seconded by um
councillor cargill uh will i'm never
going to call on
mr buckland um to carry out a role call
of the vote um
either for against or abstaining the
motion
mr buckland would you like to carry out
the role call thank you
thank you very much um councillor kettle
councillor kettle four thank you
councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you
councillor alcock
councillor [ __ ] four and cucumber parker
four councillor barker thank you uh
customer cargill council cargill four
plebe councillor cleve four
from canada curtis
councillor curtis four jeep kessler edin
councillor eddon four comes to the field
thank you councillor councillor fitter
four thank you councillor fleming
cancer flowering four that's reporting
fighting for the foreman
councillor foreman four thank you
councillor ian pretzely
councillor ian freshly paul councillor
jenny crashly
that's the journey fragility for thank
you
harris
jefferson councillor jefferson four
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings four
junaid councillor junaid iv
thank you councillor mills councillor
mills for
keller
councillor together
okay i've come back to cancel the
particular second council of richards
councillor richards for thank you
council riley
county four thank you rock
chancellor rock four thank you guys
that's the role for thank you council
shenton
thank you i'll return to councillor
togela are you there
again that was unanimous thank you
thank you councillors um i think this is
a great step forward for the council
um and uh congratulations to all
uh those who work with working party and
all the officers who've managed to
deliver this
um and i think it's it's a really
important step
following the motion we had 12 months
ago to
adopt a climate change emergency at this
council
so well done everybody um we therefore
move on to
point uh item 10 of the agenda which
is uh review of local government
structures
warwickshire and i call upon councillor
uh tony jefferson as leader of the
council
to introduce this item thank you
thank you chair this actually builds on
the agreement and cabinet
to agree to the principle of a jointly
commissioned review of local government
across
south warwickshire and the wider county
council area
i should say that the leaders of all the
districts and boroughs
have now agreed to participate in that
work
so that can move forwards uh the
background to
this is there is a review of local
government
a white paper on local government
structures coming forward probably
in september so this is
in essence preparation for that the
specific recommendations now
uh that we need to do as a council are
that the principle of shared working
with
specifically warwick district council be
confirmed as part of the adoptive policy
framework
and the agreements be entered into with
warwick district council pursuant to
section 113
of the local government act 1972 and all
other enabling powers
so that the employees can be placed at
the disposal of the other council as may
be required
subject to the leader of the council
endorsing business cases
for any such service if you remember
this originally started because warwick
district council
and ourselves were intending to work
much closer together with the
possibility of creating
a joint district
hello sorry
how's like technical hitch carry on
chair yes hello hello
i see councillor junior just indicated
she wishes to speak
thank you council junior would you like
to speak please
uh yes i i welcome closer working with
warwick district council on sharing
management posts
um exploring shared contracts principle
of working on joint core strategy it all
seems common sense
uh i was reminded by uh my predecessor
councillor morse
uh that they had that the he had and the
lo
and his group had been pressing for this
for that many years and indeed there was
a motion
proposing uh shared services in 2007
and i believe he raised it several times
afterwards
so it's a good way of sharing services
um and con joint contracts to save money
uh make improvements for the benefits of
residents
and i believe the county council
researched it also
but i just want to raise one thing
because
i agree to the principle that a review
of local government should be carried
out
and it's obvious that government is
intent on structural change to to
replace two-tier authorities
so while i believe we should do whatever
we can to make vital improvements
and to become more cost effective uh i
do also think and this is absolutely
crucial as far as i'm concerned
that we need to keep decision making
accessible local
and responsive to the needs of our
residents that must come first
and it's on this last point that i
reserve my judgment because i want to
see
all the future proposals for a reunitary
all the details until i can finally make
up my mind
about uh that detail but that at this
stage all we're talking about
is the shared working practices uh and
the contracts and management
and then a review so i i have no
problems with this particular
recommendation
thank you councilman junior counselor
you've requested to speak
thank you chair um yeah i'd just like to
echo what counselor june ed is
is saying um that the principle at this
stage is
to look at the review and see what steps
forward
what steps we take forward as a as a
district council
um i just wanted to make some one or two
other points um
i do have a problem with central
government that there
is a it feels like this there's
continuous major reform from the center
and for me i feel that that that
presents its own dangers in itself
um particularly as this distracts
district and county councils from
from actually getting on with the job
that they're there to do
um and this and i also have
still i still have an issue with um
involving the creation of larger
geographical units for the delivery of
local services bigger councils
constant central reform has a hugely
disruptive impact on local services
on the possibilities of promoting local
democratic engagement
particularly now that stratfor district
council has a huge amount to do during
cover this coveted 19 pandemic and a
fallout which we haven't had yet from
from brexit
um there's also compelling evidence
nationally and internationally
that local democratic participation
and civic engagement tends to be higher
where smaller units
smaller councils um in local government
are retained and finally
the principle of bigger is better loses
the most fundamental principle of local
government
that's the democratic accountability and
local participation
this is what we're likely to lose if we
become either a super district
or a super unitary i
fundamentally just disagree with that
policy
of uh central of the central government
and the direction of travel to become a
super council
of any kind um so um
sort of in summary happy to see the
review
and see what comes out of it um but
i i really do fear for
um accountability and local democracy
considering that voter turnout in
for uk councils is about half of that
for councils local government in europe
thank you
thank you thank you councillor patrick
uh council justin
you asked to speak
thank you chair uh i agree with
many of the sentiments that have been
expressed i think it is really
important that local government is as
close as a res
as close to the residents it serves as
possible
i think however that the world is
changing
and we at least have to explore the
options
that may face us in a changing world
with that can i propose that the
recommendations to council that are read
out
are adopted
thank you council jefferson uh and
that's been seconded by
councillor pemberton uh can you confirm
that council members look
uh orally so all councils can hear
please
thank you chair councillor pemberton
confirms seconding
we therefore have um item number 10
[Music]
proposed by council jefferson seconded
by council pemberton
um i'm therefore going to
in the absence of any other speakers i
identify their wish to speak i'm going
to ask the head of paid service mr
buckland
to carry out the royal call of members
uh on this
item uh mr buckland please
thank you chairman um and as the leader
referred to
the first two recommendations firstly
that this principle shared working with
warrant counsel district has to be
confirmed and the second recommendation
that we enter
where necessary into section 113
agreements with both district council
um i would ask again if you just
indicate with the year four against
those recommendations uh councillor
kettle
councillor kettle four thank you
councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you uh
councillor alcock
councillor o'clock four parker
councillor barker iv cargill
council cargill for keeping us with
[Music]
david curtis
open up turn against the first in the
second council
council and keep them for fielding
for thank you
thank you foreman
counselor journey fragility for kessler
harris
councillor harris ball harvey
council harvey four thank you seraphine
councillor seraphine four thank you mr
jefferson
councillor jefferson four thank you
for jennings councillor jennings four
thank you junaid councillor do you need
four
people for meals council meals for
thank you kessler o'donnell councillor
donald
four mr perry councillor parry four
pemberton council of pemberton
councillor tagalog four councillor
richards
councillor richards four thank you riley
councillor riley four people rock
councillor rock four you kick off the
road
okay i will just return to council david
curtis that's the countess are you with
us
yes i am uh councillor curtis four
thanks david thank you chairman again
that was unanimous thank you
thank you mr buckland um so that that
item number 10 is carried as mr buckland
has said unanimously
um we therefore now move on to items
refer to cancel from portfolio holders
and the first item on this section is
the lockley neighborhood development
plan
i invite council darren pemberton deputy
leader of the council to introduce this
item
thank you chairman uh members this
uh we are now looking at the locsly
neighborhood development plan
uh this follows on from a portfolio
decision published on the 7th of may um
we're now at the position where we are
looking to adopt uh
the loxley neighborhood development plan
which went to its referendum on the 27th
of february
2020 uh where the community endorsed the
plan resoundingly with an eighty six
point
four four percent yes vote um
with a ballot generating thirty nine
point four six percent
turnout and i'd like to place on uh
record my thanks to
both the members of the loxley
neighborhood development plan
team for bringing forward and for all of
their work and bringing forward
an excellent document and i'd also like
to place on record my thanks to
our policy planning team uh for
working alongside the development group
to bring the plan
to fruition we're now at the point where
we are able to recommend to council
and i do make the proposal that the
loxley neighborhood development plan
is adopted with immediate effects with
the consequence that it becomes part of
the development plan for
stratford-upon-avon districts
thank you chair
thank you mr pemberton oh sorry council
pemberton
um do i have a second for that item
council shelton you volunteered to
second the item would you like to
confirm that in uh
orally for everybody counselor shenzhen
yes i second this item
thank you um now i can just see uh on
screen that a number of people are still
having problems with the visual bit of
the um
uh the meeting um
i haven't got any messages to say people
cannot hear
uh the meeting which is a which is the
statutory requirement
um i'm just looking
um on the chat function
nobody's recorded to me that they cannot
hear and therefore
i think in the absence of the
visual bit we will continue
uh therefore we have a proposer and a
seconder for the
item the the net locked enable
development plan does anybody
wish to speak on this item
no well i have no request to speak on
this item
and therefore i suggest we go
immediately to the vote
and request mr buckland once again
to carry out a roll call of course uh mr
buckland
german thank you very much for all in
relation to the
neighborhood development plan councillor
kettle
bouncer capital four thank you
councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you
[ __ ] councillor [ __ ] for
four thank you counselor curtis
mr david curtis
okay i'll just turn it off cancel evan
four uh
fleming councillor fleming four
thank you kendall poyton councillor
thank you foreman councillor foreman
four thank you councillor ian pretzely
councillor ian frasery four thank you
jenny that's the journey financially
four
okay i will just pause and return to
councillor david curtis although
indicated on chat four can i just
confirm that it comes please please
thank you yes for
thank you councillor jackie harris
uh councillor harris for thank you
harvey
council harvey four against the
henchman's heritage
and sanchez seraphine for
jefferson councillor jefferson four
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings four
thank you for junit
mr susan junior uh councillor susan
junaid four
thank you all right councillor mills
council mills for
thank
richards councillor richards for
you riley council valley four
nikki rock councillor rock
four if you guys
thank you chairman again that was
unanimous being paid with the
recommendation thank you
uh thank you mr buckland um
we therefore have supported
that item item 11 unanimously
we move on to item 12 which is the local
development scheme april 2020
and once again uh i call on councillor
pemberton
uh a deputy leader of the council to
introduce this item counselor pemberton
thank you chairman um uh as members will
be aware this uh this was one of a
number of decisions that
fell um to be made by the leader under
the uh powers delegated uh during uh
curvy so
the uh following decision was published
on the 22nd
of april uh as a recommendation to
council
by by a background in context there is a
requirement that local plans are
prepared in accordance with our
published local development
scheme however the current lds
is is now out of date and as such
emerging plans
are at risk of being unable to pass
examination um the leader therefore
considered a number of
options uh number one to agree to update
the timetable and endorse the lds
uh to amend the timetable and accept
recommendations or not to formally
endorse the lds and of course given the
risks to local plans
option three was not considered
appropriate so
the leader's decision and the
recommendation to cancel which i
formally
propose is that the timetable for the
preparation of
local planned documents as outlined in
the report
and which were attached to the notice of
decision be approved and that the
stratford-upon-avon district local
development scheme
be revised accordingly and that the
revised local development scheme be
brought into effect
in accordance with section 15 bracket 7
close bracket
of the planning and compulsory purchase
act 2004 bracket as amended close
bracket
i i formally make that proposal to
council
thank you
thank you um council pemberton
um i'm just going to ask you a second
for that and then i'm going to take a a
brief um intermission
not from the meeting but i do have a
second
um councillor fitter you're proposing
second this item can you come
can you speak to second that item
counselor theater and i would like to
second the item
thank you council officers so we now
have proposal 12
proposed and seconded um council rock
you've asked to speak i'm just going to
ask take a brief introduction because a
question has been asked
uh by councillor ian frenchly
because i think a number of councillors
have temporarily dropped out of the
meeting
uh with a communication issue um and i
want to confirm
with um
our monitoring officer um mr kraft and i
are you there and if so please could you
comment
on mr franchise or councillor
frederick's comment that's cancer in
prejudice comment
um about the uh situation where somebody
drops
out of a meeting for a brief period
uh would you like to please mr grafton
yes i'm here chairman thank you so the
the big question is whether members can
hear
the proceedings rather than whether they
can see them
as long as we have the quorum which is
nine members of council who can hear
the proceedings then you can continue
with the business
and in the meantime i think councillors
have
access to helplines in order to get them
back on
but certainly the business can continue
until such time as we don't any longer
have a quorum which is i say is nine
members
check check chairman thank you mr
grafton the question
from mr fragile counselor frankly was if
a counselor has dropped
out of the meeting and therefore been
even
uh for a a very limited period unable to
help
hold hear the details of any debate
um should they be excluded from voting
on the item when it comes
to the vote the answer to that is
no they can vote
thank you mr grafton um
so that is clear mr graf the monetary
officer has confirmed mr
uh council fragility that despite
missing
um part of the debate
uh they ca councillors are entitled to
vote
on the on the um item being considered
at the time
i'm very much hoping uh that whilst
people have
dropped um from time to time that
they've only been out for a very
very brief period um do you
are you content with that counselor
frenchly
i i find it it's a problem that people
are voting on
about something which they haven't heard
witnessed or
contributed to any of the argument of
the debate
well we have had the view from the
monitoring officer that it is acceptable
to vote
um clearly i would hope if members
are left uh from you know the majority
of the debate
um that they um and really feel they are
unable to vote that they abstain when we
come to that vote
um i would also suggest that if any
member
does find that they have missed what
they may
feel to be a material part of the debate
that they request to speak
and request if necessary for
clarification on that item which they
may have missed
so in fact i will put that call out
because a number of people do seem to
have
logged out and logged back in again i
know council fortune for example has now
had to
log out and back in again um do any
counsellors
feel that as a result of a a break in
the transmission of the debate
that they wish to raise any items which
they may feel they have missed
either in the presentation of council
pemberton or from the subsequent
contributions from
uh other speakers uh please could
anybody
um inform me throughout the chat
function
as to whether that is something that
they wish to do
um council apparently the the majority
well the fact that as you can see
yourself there are no
counsellors currently who have
identified
a need to for clarification on any of
the items
so um i'm sure councillors will take
their responsibilities very seriously on
this item
um and i therefore propose uh that we do
move forward
clearly um and are repeated if anybody
feels that they wish to have
clarification on something that has
taken place whilst they have not been
able to hear
um the debate please ensure that you do
request for that clarification
um if you feel it's necessary um
is that okay counselor actually
yes thank you chair thank you council
franchisee right
in which case we'll go back to we do
have a we do have item
um 12 proposed and seconded
um we have one request for speaker which
is
uh councillor rock council rock would
you would you speak please
uh thank you can you hear me okay
counselor i can hear you yes okay uh
thank you very much chairman
well councillor pemberton said the other
day that he was pleased that i was
shadowing his portfolio
brief i think that's what he said anyway
um so i'm going to
venture comments uh on the next two
items as well as this one
uh upon this one this significant
slippage
uh on the policy program the site
allocation
plan is delayed by 20 months the gypsy
and traveller plan
by 25 months the development
requirements spd by 10 months and the
core strategy by 31 months
this obviously has direct costs and also
indirect costs in the risk of uh
defending uh on satisfactory planning
applications which might arise
in the meantime
without wishing to rake over the coals
at least some of the problems relate to
county council factors and their input
from that direction gypsy and traveller
science is
a thorny issue well across the country
as as
across the county as well as the country
and um
and also similarly the southern uh
area
school catchment it is resolved to and
the effect it has had on the site
allocations plan
has also a root cause
in the communications we've had with the
county
um i would say that the lack of
capacity of infrastructure uh sound them
is not only due to the college but there
are other factors there
health resource provision for instance
however um i think we have to
agree with the the program that's been
put forward
but um i would hope we would go forward
uh i'd ask the portfolio holder to see
if we can ensure better convergence
between the objectives of this council
and those of of the district uh
the county and the district in future um
let's see if we can keep the timetable
in future
but i recognize how difficult the whole
matter is
thank you mr chairman
thank you thank you councillor rock um
we therefore move on to the next item
which is sorry not the next item the
next speaker
uh counselor pemberton you wish to
respond to councillor rock's um
comments uh thank you very much chairman
um
uh just to give my uh newly welcomed
shadow
um and uh the rest of the members uh
of of the council reassurance that
our policy team are doing all that is
within their power to drive
forward uh every aspect of planning
policy
um and i as portfolio holder and
closely attuned to the challenges that
face us
in um securing an alignment of
objectives and timetables with
other stakeholders and we'll continue to
do everything within my power
to ensure that all of our stakeholders
understand
the importance of uh our core strategy
our planning policy documents and for
them to
to participate and help us in achieving
the uh the objectives of uh updating and
renewing policies in a timely fashion so
i look forward to working alongside
counselor rock
in securing that objective thank you
thank you council pemberton um
i'm just looking to see a council crump
you wish to speak
yes sir thank you mr chairman uh just
come in briefly obviously um
councillor rock did happen to mention
saturn which is my award both from a
county point of view
and a district council point of view
yeah i'm pleased that
council the pemberton um metro door
stakeholders because in particular
the town council have reviewed um
bringing him on down the licensing
authority for the market that
has recently um gone into uh
in demise and i have been liaising with
councillor shenton
on on that for some assistance so thank
you councillor shanton
looking very serious there happy
birthday
um but um yeah i think all partners do
need to be involved
we do need to make sure we've got the
infrastructure in place
in as in all our market terms but in
particular
um savannah has had him 1100 plus houses
uh this college is expanding and uh
we've got hs2 our friends uh all around
us so sometimes we're
surrounded it's a bit like a john wayne
film where we've got all the wagons in a
circle and we're being
enclosed in many areas in particular um
the i've been like realizing issues
regarding road closures because
we want to make sure our ten centers are
viable but if people can't get there
that's another issue and one of the
minor things we are trying to
you know is with as well is making it
easier and sustainable to
to get to our market turns in particular
so from from places such
as knapton where accounts of the rockets
stockton where kentucky lardon would be
and long ishington so yeah um
pleased to see that all stakeholders are
being involved
and happy to
add more to pennyworth if needed catch
the pemberton
and in particularly uh assisting the the
bowling green with its uh
uh takens as well i'm more than happy to
uh to meet you there
thank you
thank you um uh councillor trump i'm
sure um
i'll support you will be delighted to
join in the bowling green
um as when it's uh appropriate to do
um okay i'm just looking forward
uh to seeing if anybody else wishes to
speak on this item
um i have no uh other requests to speak
therefore i'm going to ask the
head of paid service mr buckland once
again to call the role
on this item uh counselors vote for
against rob stein after reading out
their name mr buckland
dixon can confirm that i've got limited
vision but i have heard everything
perfectly fine
four
in
4. councillor
foreman four councillor ian frenchly
councillor ian fletcher four thank you
so jenny frenchly
how's the generally fragile thank you
tesla harris
for harris four thank you guys
councillor harvey four newcastle
hinchester
and chesterfin four thank you jefferson
council jefferson for jennings
council of jennings for junit
councillor junaid four thank you
councillor mills
council murals for thank you oh donal
councillor o'donnell for the newcastle
parry
councillor parry for you pemberton
councillor pemberton four councillor
potoguella
a rock
that's how much you work
cancer the rock four thank you that
council of roth
casserole four thank you councillor
shenton
shout out to councillor fielding uh
because with john fielding are you there
very very faint castle clearly but we
did pick it up i'm chairman again that
was unanimous with 33 votes for
thank you
thank you um uh mr buckland
um can i just chris mr fielding cancer
fielding your
um to reiterate uh if you could speak
either louder or slightly closer to the
microphone that would be helpful
thank you um right moving on
um we have therefore got to
um
uh item number 13 which is dropped by
the infrastructure funding statement
2018
2019 and i invite counselling again
councillor darren pemberton
as deputy leader of the council uh to
introduce this item
council pension thank you once again
chair
uh again this is an item uh where the
decision has been made by the leader
under the
emergency arrangements decision on the
22nd
of april uh it forms the recommendation
to
to cancel the background is that there
is a requirement upon this authority to
have an infrastructure funding statement
arising out of recent government reforms
to the
community infrastructure levy and that
include the
abolition of the so-called one
regulation 123 list
the infrastructure funding statement
should be
an annually updated document comprising
three elements
an infrastructure list covering the
infrastructure projects or types of
infrastructure
that we intend to fund or partly fund
a report setting out sill and s106
standard information on income and
expenditure for the relevant financial
year
and a revised spending protocol
the revised infrastructure statement
has been prepared in conjunction with
with officers
and a number of projects have been
submitted and assessed
against
the criteria within the ifs and
18 projects are on the infrastructure
list
so members uh the recommendation to
council
which i propose is that the
infrastructure funding statement for
2018-19
be adopted and that the existing
regulation 123 list
be rescinded upon adoption of the new
infrastructure funding statement for
2018-19 i'll now defer to
councillor rock for questions
uh thank you do you have a second of
your proposal uh council pemberton
council cargill uh you volunteered to
second could you please
confirm that overlay please
cancel your second proposal
thank you councillor uh cargill we have
a proposal action 13 proposed
second dude uh i'm now going to call on
councillor rock who's indicated you wish
to
speak thank you very much
thank you very much mr chairman i i
thank councillor pemberton for uh
anticipating my um intervention um
and um as in the previous item i'm not
going to suggest we tear the whole thing
up
um however i just would point point
out something and i particularly wanted
to allude to the issue of
cycle tracks now there are uh three
cycle routes already on the list
uh but in fact um we're rather hamstrung
by the county council's position on uh
cycle routes
which uh their policy is only to support
urban and inter-urban cycle routes
now we've got a large rural district um
and the only one that that falls within
their remit
if a cycle route forms part of a
national network
so if we want to put something that
benefits our local residents
for instance and this is something and
um
councillor crump will be only too well
aware of this we're trying to
connect some of the villages that circle
south and
i'm sure the same thing applies to other
market towns
we're not able to do that because of the
county council's policies
so i wonder going forward if we're
uh able to lobby or work with the county
council
about a policy that's quite unsuitable
for our residents in aurora district
um because if we want to put these cycle
routes in
which appears to be the movement of the
government they want to see this sort of
thing
uh if we've got um villages as in my own
ward and
uh as in cancer adam's ward who's been
working with us on this uh and i'm sure
around shipston
and and studly there might be other
situations
we're not able to do it because the
county council's
barring us because of their policy so i
think we
we can support the uh the motion that's
written but i would ask um
the portfolio holder to see if we could
perhaps have a look at
how that works thank you chairman
thank you council rock um councillor
pemberton
are you responding to councillor rock's
comments
thank you thank you chair yes yes indeed
um um certainly uh you
you'll note that uh um
catalog is absolutely right around the
the council's policy the county
council's policy and uh it is certainly
something that we are
engaged with um i think the the picture
is going to move significantly in any
event uh
as it seems clear that there is a a move
from central government
um which we've already seen given life
to in terms of the temporary covid19
measures to
improve cycle access and take up
across the whole of the country both in
urban
and uh rural settings um so i i have the
feeling that uh
there will be change um uh if not uh
willingly entered into but
uh enforced by central government around
the future recycle ways
and i will of course endeavor to
encourage the county council to
develop policies that meet all of the
the needs of all residents of stratford
district
thank you
right thank you for that response
council pemberton um
now i have no other requests to speak
um i should give everybody a short brief
uh
moment um and if we if we're not we have
a proposal
um item number 13 has been proposed by
council pemberton
seconded by um council cargill
uh and therefore if we i'm going to
request
um mr buckland once again to carry out
local councillors to vote either for
against or abstain having mentioned your
name
thank you mr buckland thank you chairman
just for clarification
that the recommendations are shown on
page 58 of the agenda
um councillor kettle
how's the cattle for
dixon
curtis
that's our david curtis
okay our counselor eden councillor evan
four
thank you councillor fielding councillor
fielding
for that's much better thank you guys
for feeling like comes to fitter
counselor fitter for fleming
councillor fleming four thank you that's
my point
factually for you harris
special jackie harris
harris that's the harvey council harvey
four
thank you that's the hint of seraphine
council andrew serafin
four thank you jefferson
councillor jefferson four thank you
council jennings
councillor jennings sport
councillor junior iv thank you that's my
meals
council meals for thank you
councillor o'donnell four thank you
harry
councillor parry four thank you
pemberton
councillor pemberton four thank you
councillor
keller councillor four
rock four vicky that's the wolf
castle roll four thank you kevin shenton
councillor shenton four kessler wally
hoggins
council of wally hoggins for thank you i
will just try once more
our counselor david curtis
no okay and councillor harris council
jackie harris are you there please
yeah i did reply for some reason it
didn't come through but jackie harris
poor please
thank you very much um jim we had 32
votes for
and none against um unfortunately we
didn't record a vote from cancer curtis
on that one thank you
thank you mr buckland um i noticed mr
mr curtis and council council is
i think out of the meeting at the moment
um
so we therefore move on to that that
item is carried we therefore move on to
item 14 which is revised committing
infrastructure levy informants policy
20th july uh another reporting point of
view but i think council pemberton is
going to be
moving this recommendation council thank
you thank you
yes indeed i i am and the background
to this members is that for the
community infrastructure
levy uh for for large levy payments
and there is a well-established policy
um
whereby in essence uh developers will
make uh installment payments of their
sill charges to typically be in line
with the the phasing of developments
or as they are built out and this policy
kicks in
uh for sil charges in excess of twenty
thousand pounds
um following on from uh pandemic central
government have issued
uh guidance encouraging the local
clinical authorities
uh to to relapse the fate
of uh payments on large scale schemes
and this policy takes to do exactly that
this is a temporary measure and once the
the impacts of covert 19 on the
construction industry have have settled
tan
it is our full intention to revert back
to our standard
uh approach to installment payments
um members will note that the revised
policy alters the existing policy by
adding six months to each of the payment
deadlines
this will provide some some assistance
uh
to developers and ensure that we
continue to have
uh sites brought on stream and and
brought through to
to conclusion um that will ensure that
the
uh the infrastructure payments are made
and the sites are
are built out so uh members the the
recommendation
to council which again i am proposing is
that the revised
community infrastructure levy
installments policy
be adopted with effect from july the
20th
2020
and i look for a seconder for that and
uh we'll uh of course deal with
questions from councillor rock thank you
um councilman pemberton um councilman
simpson
you are looking in fact i think council
feature to it uh council jefferson are
you you're seconding that proposal can
you confirm that please
counselor jefferson i am second in the
proposal
right thank you for that we therefore
have the proposal
item number 14 proposed and seconded
um and i have now got a request
i think from council council rock to
speak please
council rock i'm afraid it's me again
chairman um uh i fully support
this um this change i think it's a good
idea to
encourage developers um i'm going to
suggest we do one other thing and
possibly that requires me to propose an
amendment but uh
uh possibly the portfolio holder will
consider it friendly
um at the moment this is an open-ended
change there's no sunset clause or
review
it it carries on for the currency of the
covid crisis
which is a bit of a um unspecified
period
and now i do think if we want to
encourage develop
developers to get on with it and we also
want to review
the the the benefit that we are giving
to developers
there probably should be a review date
on that
and uh i would suggest we we could
review this
in a period possibly six months um
when i i think that would be a useful
thing to do um
now i defer to the portfolio holder if
you'd like to take that away and do it
or i can
propose that as a formal amendment now
whatever he thinks is most useful
can i ask that question the portfolio mr
chairman
um yes well i will ask um council
pemberton
on your behalf council rock council
pemberton you've requested
um whether you will accept
uh council rock's friendly amendment to
that or whether you would uh require
uh council rock's proposal to be
amendment to be proposed and second
inversion on
thank you thank you
for for council rocks and for for
members uh there was consideration given
to
uh whether there should be a a sunset
clause for this
and actual actually the practical
difficulty is that we really have
no at this point real
understanding or clarity as to when the
construction industry
is um going to be in a position
for us to um you know reintroduce the
standard installments policy and for
that very reason
uh there was no sunset clause uh brought
with this recommendation um i think what
i
would i would ask of uh councillor rock
and and uh
and of members of the council is to
is to note that um it is this
authority's
um backstop policy that the the uh that
you know the dates
uh are there and this is only a
temporary measure
and i think what i would be suggesting
is that internally with
with policy with the policy team we will
be keeping
um abreast on developments and the
recovery of
the um of the
construction industry and i will
undertake to
uh engage with counsellor rock in those
discussions and those updates as of when
we get better data
so that we can so that he can have
assurance
uh that we will bring uh this temporary
measure to
to a halt at the earliest practical time
i would be
uncomfortable with setting um what is in
fact
an artificial sunset clause at this
point because we can't be clear on
when it should operate uh and that could
be in a position where we would then
have to debate something
further down the track and it and expand
it i think if councilor rock is happy uh
to to work alongside me on this uh we
can then bring something together
uh further down the track um and i see
that uh
uh i see council lock as a as indicated
in
in
to speak so that that's where i would be
at with that
that we work together and then bring
something further
down the track when there's more clarity
about the recovery thank you chair
council rock you've had a response from
council feminism do you wish to
um come back on that point yes yes with
your indulgence chairman speaking twice
but
uh i'm happy to accept that uh
reassurance
uh um from council of pemberton that's
um
i think that's the correct way to go
forward so thank you very much mr
chairman
thank you so um do we have anybody else
wishing to speak on this item
i've got nobody indicating through the
chat function they wish to speak
and therefore i'm going to once again
ask mr buckland
to carry the roll call uh on this motion
um it is proposed and seconded uh so can
we
mr butler can you carry out the wrong
call please thank you chairman
the recommendation is shown on page
thank you councillor
thank you victoria um
[Music]
thank you i will call out to councillor
david curtis see you there now or have
you left
oh god
okay hello curtis is left um councillor
evan
against reading four if you cut the
field in
the fielding four thank you
council of fitter four thank you
councillor fleming
councillor
ian presley councillor ian flaglee paul
jenny that's the journey for actually
four
thank you councillor harris councillor
harris four
harvey council harvey four
thank you council henches seraphine
angela andrew serafin
for thank you jefferson councillor
jefferson
four thank you jennings councillor
german school
junip councillor
thank you pemberton nessler pemberton
four
thank you casper councillor pertegalla
four
thank you councillor richards councillor
richard sport
thank you kessler riley councillor
valley
four thank you castle rock councillor
rock
four thank you uh castle vault has left
the meeting and councillor shenton
councillor shenton four and comes by
wally hoggins
we therefore move on to item 15 these
are matters
for noting by the council and the first
one
is the following items were considered
under urgency for urgency provisions
provided for in the council's
constitution
at the meeting of the cabinet on the 6th
of july 2020 and
reported here for information only the
first
of these items is the reopening of the
leisure center
the second uh which has been covered by
agenda item 10 above
is a review of the local government
structures
and the third item is pavement licenses
councils uh council requests to note the
amendment the head of regulatory
services delegated powers
set house in the scheme of delegations
uh houses
do you wish to speak yes i do i just
want to
have it made clear that uh the
recommendation on the reopening of
leisure centers which i
welcome um in the wording it seems to be
that we're
paying an additional 80 000 in actual
fact because there's already a
commitment
uh for forty thousand this is for a
maximum extra of forty thousand that's
the one on the leisure center
and on the pavement licensing uh i just
wanna
again welcome the simplified process but
i
wonder whether there's been sufficient
clarity from the county council
because i've certainly had an issue uh
locally where
there has been some confusion caused by
the county council having a different
view
on the uh the bill than the uh district
council
thank you councillor junaid um can i
suggest some
uh are you would you wish to respond to
council junior on this item
uh yes thank you chair uh
councillor jones is absolutely right the
net cost
of um reopening the leisure centers
is 40 000 over and above what the
previous costs
costs were and i have to say
uh i think uh julie lewis has done
a tremendous job in negotiating that
deal
i think it was excellent because the
starting point was way way
above anything like 40 000
and i think on the pavement licenses
we await the act with interest to see
exactly what it says
thank you thank you council jefferson
for that does anybody else wish to speak
on these items
in which case um we
move forward um now
council willie hoggins has requested the
item about planning committees
um i'm just going to seek clarification
on that
that will be carried out council willie
hoggins under urgent items
number 20 not at this stage
right we therefore move on to
other items counsellor's questions
we have received eight questions from
councillors
which have been circulated and available
on teams
now they will be displayed on screens
on screen but i'm fully aware
uh that a number of councils will not
have access to this
um given the fact that the visual part
of the meeting seems to have
malfunctioned somewhat so i will just
summarize the questions
they are on my screen i'm hoping
everybody else
does have access to them but the first
council
items for council to purchase who i
believe
still to be absent from the meeting
um i'm just going to check if i may
david curtis is not from the meeting at
the moment
uh council curtis has um
requested information um
that in relation to meetings between
developers and leadership councils has
had a response from
councillor pemberton in the absence of
council of curses um we clearly cannot
have a supplemental question on this
item
um and therefore we will
move on to the next item
which is a question for councillor
jenny franchitti counselor jenny
franklin your question
um
carry on yeah if
august turns out to be um very very good
weather
i would just like the council to be
flexible
in perhaps allowing some uh selling of
coffees etc etc
on the road from our local independent
cafes
to keep an open mind as to those
possibilities
as our cafes are very much under stress
at the moment
thank you councillor tragedy now that
question was responded by council
shenzhen council ascension do you wish
to respond to the supplementary question
please
uh only to very simply say that
obviously
if we get representations from the
businesses
we will look at them at that point
thank you thank you councilman
um we therefore move on to question
number three which is from councilman
rock and i'm
sure that everybody can read these
questions uh so i'm not going to
summarize them
thank you for that council hamilton um
councillor rock you had a response
um for your question from council
shenton
and council do you have a supplementary
question
yes chairman yes uh thank you i
particularly like to thank uh councillor
shenton for his reply which is about um
the continuing closure of
the uh waste recycling sites on
uh in the east of the district the
effect that's having on uh
on refuge collection for the district uh
responsibilities what not least flight
tipping
um and i would particularly like to
thank him because he's taken the trouble
to get a response from warwickshire
county council so that's very much
appreciated
um would he agree with me though that uh
the response from warwickshire county
council that suggests
because because the sites are small they
can't manage
social distancing now the stockton
uh waste recycling center which is um
services my ward and that of um the
members in south in particular as well
as those
uh cancer adam in long ishington is 28
meters by 40 meters
outside so i find it difficult to
believe
that social distancing and other
covid prevention measures is bigger than
most shots
would he agree with me that um possibly
warranty county council could look at
that again
council uh simpson would you like to
comment on that please
thanks for sharing are you are you with
us would you like to respond to
councillor rock's
follow-up question thank you chairman
for some reason my
my uh mute button failed to work there
and what i will say on this matter
is that i put my trust in
in warwick county council on this
the safety of of the operatives there
is equally as important as the safety of
people that use
the site and therefore
i'm quite content i've raised this issue
with
the county council on a number of
occasions received
similar answers and as far as i'm
concerned
i will put my face in their judgment
they operate the site
and their only um only the only reason
for not opening
this site well the two sites is purely
to for safety reasons i'm sure in time
we might be able to relax
that but in the meantime they they
we must go with what warwick county
council say on this
thank you thank you councillor jensen
um move on to question four councillor
juned um council junior you you've
um got a response from council jensen
again
uh on your item do you have a
supplemental question
no i i no no supplementary question i'm
quite happy with the res
with the answer at the moment
thank you counselor junaid um now
counselor kate rolfe
um has asked the next question uh but
has um
messaged me to say that she has had to
leave the meeting
um for reasons beyond her control
um are not to do with it or
communications
um which she has apologized uh therefore
um not the supplementary question on
cape
uh councilwolf's question um
we therefore move on to uh item numbers
question number six which is counselor
person guella
councillor pertiguella um to remind you
you have the option of asking a
supplementary question uh you've had a
response from councillor barker
uh do you have a supplemental question
to following that response
uh no i don't have a supplementary
question uh thank you chair
thank you councillor um we therefore
move on to
question number seven which is from
councillor victoria orcock
[Music]
you've had a response from council
pemberton
do you have a supplemental question no
no
thank you thank you
and the final question is from
councillor cleve
uh council cleve you've um had a
response from council justin
do you have a sacramento question
following that response
right in which case that ends um
question
counselors questions uh we therefore
move on to
item 17 which is questions to
the leader and
i know a number of you have already
identified halfway through that
um previous section uh that you have
questions
um i'm therefore going to
run through the order which i think that
they're in uh which is firstly
council jennings you have a question for
the leader
councillor jennings a question for the
leader i know that you've been doing
extensive lobbying on behalf of the
district
what lessons have you learned
council justin what an interesting
question
councillor jennings uh we have indeed
been doing very extensive lobbying
and i've been very heavily involved in
it uh
as i said in the leaders statement at
the front
um we've been lobbying both in terms of
the financial position of the council
and the position of the district uh
i think what's absolutely key is to
actually
marshal the arguments and the evidence
and that is really important and i go
back to one of the things that came out
very early on and that is getting across
the message that with the fourth hardest
hit district
and that seems to resonate the other
thing is and this is where both
council officers and cabinet working
closely together is paid dividends
we've got to make sure that everyone's
on the same
page and he's telling the same story and
i think that worked well
to be fair the officers did most of the
lobbying
on the financial position of the council
but i mean they we discussed the
financial position of the council
extensively in cabinet meetings with the
officers
you've also got to use every channel and
every opportunity
to get the messages across so in my case
that's been the county council
it's been the lap it's been the west
midlands combined authority and it's
been in meetings
with various departments
and i have to say that meetings in
face-to-face lobbying
works far and away the best the other
thing that i think has come across very
clearly
is repetition really matters
keep repeating the same story when it
gets across
and also try to get the message retold
by others
so one of the big advantages of lobbying
the county council and the leppy's
they then pick up the message and repeat
it
and that again is about mobilizing
support
and finally persistence really pays and
is really important
and you just don't stop and we're not
stopping now
so thank you councillor jennings i hope
that answers the question
question yeah thank you thank you leader
that's a very full and comprehensive
answer thank you
um council fielding you have a question
for a leader
i do indeed thank you very much um
leader we had a um i have a very good
agriculturalist
in plan well who is based up in the
planning department
who understands and knows about trees
and ptos and etc
we had a meeting uh commit
committee meeting uh where the main
issue was to do
with trees um and the
agriculturalist had spoken to the land
owner that
wanted to develop a house none of this
information
was passed across to the planning
the planners and when i queried it i was
told
that we've had enough experience as
planners to understand
trees well i've had 15 years or i had 15
years and passed a number of exams
in arboriculture and forestry
and i feel that if you've got an expert
we should use the expert
and the correspondence that she has made
should be
put on file
thank you councillor justin
thank you i think that really is a
matter for the officers to take up
and i would recommend that they do so
thank you jefferson well well not really
you have your last question uh let me
just say uh
that other people have a question and
we'll come back to you okay
um counselor junaid
if i if i might i have two questions
actually
um yesterday i became aware of a problem
locally in the scheme for free school
meals over the summer holidays
apparently there is a deadline for
application of today
july the 13th only children who qualify
for school meals
by their application deadline will
receive those school
meals the children of parents who lose
their jobs from today onwards
over the summer will not be eligible so
those are
our children who will not receive free
school meals
even though their parents have lost
their job could the leader please make
representation
on behalf of local residents to the
stratford mp
to raise this issue in question that was
not my number one question
the second one is could the leader also
confirm when the district council's
own economic recovery working group will
actually start
as i'm meant to be on that
uh in response to the first question yes
uh in response to the second question
we've not said today yet
but we're discussing it this morning
when we met with the senior officers
thank you jefferson thank you councillor
junior
we therefore move on to the next
question which is councillor ian
frenchly
uh thank you chair um i understand that
our local nhs key workers
now have to pay for parking their
vehicles whilst at work
we do have a great dependency on our nhs
workers
and their dedication to our town and
district
as illustrated by yourself earlier on
today chair
so please could i ask the leader to open
up arden street in windsor street car
parks
for them for free parking whilst they're
at work
thank you thank you councillor frankly
it will be something we consider but i
would remind councillor frankly
that car parking income is a major
source of revenue for the council
and at the moment uh we need
all the revenue we can get and if the
nhs
has actually stopped free car parking
for nhs
staff i failed to see why we should
subsidize them
the nhs thanks thank you
council jefferson um we therefore move
our next question which is cancer
fleming
ah yeah um we heard earlier uh
leader that uh you had a slightly
pessimistic view for the high streets
and we all know what the short term is
and nobody's expecting you to
answer a long term sort of prognosis but
how do you see things moving along for
the high streets in the medium term
thank you councillor fleming you've
really pulled a very difficult question
at me
um there is no doubt about it the high
streets are going to struggle
even before this curved crisis hit there
were too many shops
i think that's well accepted uh
while the curvy crisis has been going on
internet
sales as a percentage of retail sales
has gone from 20
to 30 percent which puts even further
strain on them
an awful lot of retail operations have
far too much debt
far too much debt which is our
actually hello yeah
you can suggest something can you could
you just leave me alone
that's justin hello council justin can
you
rewind
okay right yeah my screen went totally
blank i don't know what happened
i was saying that an awful lot of retail
organizations have fought in much debt
i will just point out that everyone on
my screen now is frozen
can you still hear me
yes yes yes council justin okay
that is actually causing quite a lot of
organizations to fail
there's almost no doubt about it the
rents are far too high
and the amounts of negotiation
renegotiation of rents that are going on
are very considerable i think there's
also no doubt the business rates are too
high but that'll get reviewed
footfall is way way way down
the messages i pick up from the west
midlands combined authority is
footfall is between 40 and 50 percent
of normal uh that will be enforced by
our car parking uh records that show
car parking is down between 40 and 50
percent
the other thing and this one really did
surprise me
office workers are not coming back in
the same numbers as before
most of the big offices in birmingham
are not expecting people to start coming
back until september
so i actually think that in many ways
we are going to see the high street
facing a
perfect storm so i think that
unfortunately
an awful lot of closures are going to be
inevitable
i wish it weren't the case but i think
it is
i think there's going to be a need for
some very creative reinvention
of the high streets and hopefully lower
rents and lower rates will make that
possible
thank you thank you for that reply
thank you councillor jefferson thank you
councillor fleming um
councillor fortrick you have a question
for the leader
thank you chairman um with the
recreation ground
uh being widely used in in stratford and
um
and enjoyed by local residents and and
visitors
um i've seen some uh
some other councils actually mark out
white
circles to encourage groups to be in
their own bubble if you like
to encourage social distancing is this
something stratfor district council
could look at so as to give residents
and visitors reassurance
that stratfor district council always
wanted to keep people safe
um that's that's my first question
and um my second question is
um how does the leader
feel uh whether the district council
along with the county council
whether they've covered themselves in
glory in how they've handled the traffic
changes in stratfor town center
regarding covid the kovit 19 pandemic
uh picking up your first question
uh council of fiji i think it is an
interesting idea it is something we
could look at
uh i do notice however that when i've
walked down
the wreck on the weekend people do
seem to be maintaining a fair amount of
distance
on the second question
i would respond that the roads and the
highways
are a county council responsibility
uh we have been lobbying hard for the
changes that have been put in
hello can you hear me yes counselor
carol and council jefferson now i've
finished thank you council jefferson
um we therefore move on to the latest
question which i think is from
councillor jenny fragili
thank you chair sorry can you start
again council generally frankly
um there's an ongoing problem which
we're
trying to deal with and i've just had
his whole series of emails about it
it's the parking of motorcycles on the
residence side
of the pavement on waterside
it doesn't seem to be able to find any
kind of solution satisfactory to
residents i've seen motorcycles drive
there i've seen most
motorcycles locked to the cycle racks
and cyclists not being able to get in i
do think we need
a roundtable talk at some point
with county police possibly to see what
solutions can can be found for that it's
uh
residents are beginning to get very very
very concerned
thank you uh
i think that was more of a statement
that a question
counselor frantically but more than
so can we have a round table uh talk
with the district the county and the
police i think those are the three
elements that need to get together
councillor frankly i just said yes to
that
right thank you thank you for that um
council twitter
councillor thank you chairman thank you
um so the leader how how long do you
think it will take
for the tourism industry to recover uh
specifically in
in distracted by open districts
um thank you councillor fitter another
rather challenging question
i think the first thing to understand is
actually this scale of tourism as it
affects
uh stratfor district uh
in 2018 we had nearly seven million
visitors
it contributes half a billion to the
local economy
supports 9 000 jobs and it was a success
story growing at over 12
per annum it's going to be slow
to get back that's absolutely clear
people don't want to be indoors which
impacts directly on the rsc and the
birthplace trust
it'll be next year before widespread
confidence
returns and i mean it is really quite
worrying to see
some of the stats uh provided by
shakespeare's
england about how little confidence
people have
uh international travel is way down it
will be slow to rebuild
coach travels halting and be slow to
recover
we know arts and heritage is badly hit
uh rsc unlikely to open in 2020 and one
of the interesting things i've learned
is that they need to be uh have the
booking system
for three months before a performance
happens to give the bookings time to
build up
my real concern is that the ecosystem
for one of a better word that supports
tourism
will deteriorate which could have medium
and long-term
consequences uh we're working with the
lack
the birthplace trust and the rfc and
shakespeare's england
on a recovery plan phase one is mainly
going to be about
domestic staycations stage two
is going to be about international we
need to be seen to invest
in the offer of stratfor to remain
competitive
and we need to build on the brands
shakespeare and stratford upon haven i
think we are
in for a very long haul i would think it
would be 2022
before we really start to get back to
anything
close to 2018 levels
and i'm sorry but all my screen appears
utterly frozen at the moment so i hope
you can still hear
i was me yes we had we heard all of that
thank you for that response
even though it wasn't terribly um cheery
um council foreman you're next on my
list
yes thank you chair would the leader
agree with me
that the county council should be asked
to reconsider its informal decision
to commission a separate business case
for a single unitary council
and instead to participate in the joint
study with the other borough and
district councils
to look at all options and to listen to
the public views
i would agree wholeheartedly counselor
foreman
and this discussions with the county
council
are ongoing and we all hope they can be
persuaded to participate fully
thank you leader thank you councillor
performance and council jefferson um
councillor joe cleave you've got a
question for the leader
yes thank you these are both questions
i've got two questions they've both been
asked me by residents recently
um so i'm not sure if you can answer or
not um
first one is does stratford uh district
council alongside the community safety
partnership carry out a risk assessment
before they place people in temporary
accommodation
this is not relating to the emergency
accommodation um
on the covid but just in general and my
second question is
now the community shield hub has closed
what are people who are still
shielding until at least the 31st of
july to do
thank you you councillor cleve
i'm afraid i don't have the technical
expertise to answer those questions now
uh i will uh check up and i will give
you a written response to them
thank you leader thank you
um there is a there is a
comment that this is one question for
leadership not not multiple people could
try and
restrict their questions to one
counselor uh henchmen therapy you've got
a question
to for the leader okay thank you chair
um the national planning framework
requires the council to identify sites
to meet the accommodation and needs of
the gypsy traveler
community since 2014
stratford district council has been
preparing a plan which will identify
sites guidance it is now 2020
six years on since this work
commenced when will the plan be
published
because the lack of the plan is leading
to green belt sites
being inappropriately used leader
thank you councillor henshaw serothin um
i have to say that the number of times
we've been around
iterations about the gypsy and
travellers plan
uh are almost too numerous to mention
uh we have tried to work with the county
council to identify sites
and as yet they haven't delivered
something it is obviously something that
now needs to be given
serious priority once we get more or
less back to normal
a specific time or date okay thank you
thank you councillor pertiguella a
question for the leader
thank you chair um the local development
scheme which the council has just
adopted
indicates july to september for informal
stakeholder
engagement in relation to the site
allocation plan
and i understand that thursday the 16th
of july is the first stakeholder
engagement with board members
and some more dates with parish council
are planned
the meonvale woodland walk is part of a
site
proposed for inclusion in the site
allocation plan
would the leader agree with me that
neonvale residents are the most
important
stakeholders in this case because
they're users of the woodland work
and if so how can they then be formally
engaged
in this period too and make their views
known about the proposed inclusion
on of the meonville woodland in the
emerging site allocation plan
well thank you councillor i think once
again that is something i need to take
away and look at and i will respond to
you in writing
within the next week
okay thank you
my screen is now gone completely dead
you might want to log out and log in
again thank you for that
sorry i was i was speaking with my
microphone switched off
uh we have um run up to 30 minute
um so not four questions the leader
uh as long as the leader is happy there
are a couple more questions
um and i'm going to suggest that we do
just have those questions it is the
first time since we've met
in since february um so using my
discretion as long as council is happy
we have a question from councilman
junior and councilman mills
um and then i'm going to close the uh
questions for the leader
uh council julie uh
councillor jeanette my questions were
already asked earlier
well that was very brief cancer junior
thank you
mills your last question thank you mr
chairman
um leader i i had a call over the
weekend i think you've almost answered
my question already
um about how long one-way system is
going to be going on in um
in stratford um so
i think you say it's it's down to
counter council but uh
i mean is this going to go on do you
think until the covet
um 19 um
crisis is over do you know any idea
thank you i find that very hard to
answer councillor mills but all i can
say is
i get bombarded almost every time i walk
down the street
about the uh the road works and the
situation of the roads
and i suspect it will need to be
reviewed sooner rather than later
okay thank you very much leader thank
you
um right that concludes uh questions to
the leader i'm sure
justin will be grateful for that um
good um item 18 notices
uh motions on notice um now an item
has been proposed by council party
guella and seconded by
councillor rock um now in accordance
with
council procedure rules um i'm reporting
on the motion
um but that it will be once proposed and
seconded
will refer to cabinet of consideration
and report without debate today um
so uh councillor rock uh council
partyella
could you um propose your motion please
yes thank you chair i'm formally
proposing uh the motion
for the council to request the technical
guidance
notes on class q for this district be
drawn up and
introduced as a matter of urgency
thank you and you've got a secondary
council rock can you confirm your second
in that motion
uh our second emotion chairman right
we there have a pro proposal and
secondary and as i've already outlined
uh that item will refer to the cabinet
for consideration
uh without further debate today and that
is
um together that is absolutely standard
procedure within their summation
um therefore we move on to item 19
and this is for noting um i have um i
did make this point earlier on um
we had in february the report up to the
end of december
and that we've now got financial report
to councillors
um for the first two months of the new
financial period
uh and we have not been given a position
of um
the financial position for the year-end
that was shown to cabinet
i'm therefore going to request officers
to circulate
two members the financial position a
summary of the financial position
for 12 months so that councils are made
fully aware
of the financial position for the period
2019 to 2020. uh is that
acceptable um uh mr buckland
chairman
get
yeah just to clarify whilst uh
recognizing the chair
um uh is keen on
regular updates um the chair is also
aware that there's a specific
group looking at the finances in the
recovery
uh and i i was in a meeting with senior
officers this morning
talking about bandwidth and their
ability to do things and
i'm just a little bit concerned that
officers are going to be asked to
duplicate a piece of work
when there's a specific uh council
recovery group looking at finances
and budgeting and i'm i just wonder
whether the chairman might wish to
uh to roll back on his request for
updated information
in a position where the thing is moving
so fast that we've got a special group
on it and
i perhaps think we should you know let
that group look at
um at the numbers and let the officers
work that through
um you know rather than actually you
know ask for a further
uh piece of work to be done at this time
and i would ask the chairs for bearings
around that please
thank you clemson um the information has
already been prepared
and produced for cabinets all i'm asking
is it should be circulated to members
it isn't asking for any further work to
be done by any officer at all
other than the other um
forwarding that information around to
all councillors um i completely accept
because i sit on that group
uh the review group which is looking
forward to seeing what's going to happen
um to the council's finances over the
next um
uh three six nine 24 months whatever
uh this is a historical record of what
happened for the financial period ending
uh march 2020 and i said that report has
already been prepared
um i'm absolutely on board we don't want
to overload officers with any new one
um anyway we'll move on then um item 20
um we've got an item of urgent business
which is um i'm going to ask
uh for portfolios of council justin but
i'm going to ask
mr grafton the monitoring officer to
introduce this
item uh mr grafton would you like to
choose society please
yes thank you so um
this report comes to you as an urgent
item because of our recent
experience of planning committee
meetings
trying to clear the backlog that built
up during the
lockdown and particularly in the period
when
planning decisions were delegated to
officers
what we have in effect is at the
beginning of
the time when planning committee
meetings were reintroduced
when we had a total of 22 applications
waiting to be dealt with
we are now faced with a situation where
that has doubled
to 44 and so we have a situation where
the demand for
planning committee to make meetings is
growing
whilst it looks like the backlog isn't
being cleared
in response to that we've increased the
frequency of planning meetings
they're currently meeting alternately a
one week and b the next week but it
might be necessary for
for us to increase that frequency so
that we hold
both a and b meetings every week
there's one thing that council can help
with and that is
in terms of the quorum for planning
committee meetings
sometimes we have face difficulty in
establishing a quorum
either at the start of or during a
planning committee meeting
currently as members will know that the
membership of each
a and b meeting is nine but the quorum
is
five the proposal is that we reduce the
quorum to
three now in saying this i want to be
clear
that this does not affect the number of
members on the committee which will
remain at nine
and nor does it affect the requirement
for
political balance on both of those
committees
thank you
thank you mr grafton um now
council of jefferson you've asked to
respect to speak on this one
that was jefferson are you with us
i think in view of the drawing
backlogging planning i think this is
actually
quite a sensible proposal uh
the one thing i think that isn't clear
is how long it will last and maybe we
want to think about
some set clause on that mr grafton
we we do have another council meeting in
october
um so that might be the opportunity at
which
we review the position
thank you mr grafton um
counselor when hoggins uh portfolio hall
of faming would you like to speak on
this
yeah i will i will say a few words thank
you i just just wanted to say
thank you to the chairs of the
committees because there's been several
meetings about this
short notice last week and that is
representative
of the fact that we all have to get get
behind this
for a council which is committed to
supporting businesses and community
recover
recovery we simply cannot allow the
situation to continue
we've got a backlog i believe currently
at the end of last week it was a
at 44. and in anticipation of this
going through i would like to thank each
and every member
of those committees who are really going
to help
businesses and communities thrive thank
you very much indeed and to recover
thank you
thank you councillor junior councillor
uh i'm sorry councilwoman holdings
councillor junaid
i haven't spoken here so i actually
thank you council do you know
yeah um council councillor jeanette um
i have no problems with the quorum
i have no problems with catching up with
the backlog but can i make a point
that four hour long meetings as the last
one was
are just too strenuous uh to be done on
such a regular basis if if counsellors
could be a little bit more succinct
in their comments maybe we will be able
to get through those meetings
a little faster you know four hours is
is beyond um you know what most
counsellors can do
and the final thing is that uh we still
have some counsellors who are waiting
for
adequate training and that needs to be
addressed as soon as possible
thank you councillor judith um moving on
rock you wish to speak thank you
chairman uh like uh councillor junior
and councillor wally hoggins
i have no problem uh with the intent of
reducing the quorum to get through the
business
but i think we we could look up some
other things to do and i would be
interested to know
um how many applications
in the backlog are due to um
can i call it a buy we get we gave the
applicant i believe
in the in the temporary covered
arrangements uh an ability to ask
for something to go to committee which
otherwise wouldn't have done so
normally it only goes to committee if
the war member or parish council comes
to a contrary view to the planning
officer
but i think we also allowed an applicant
who is going to be refused
to go to committee and i wondered how
many in the pipeline are like that
and whether we're going to get something
referred to committee
basically we're going to nod it through
with the uh
with the recommended day from the
officer and i wondered how
sensible it is doing it in that way
um i also note because i was in that
four hour meeting that to councillor
june had referred to um i suspect
we could do a bit more and in the
pre-meeting run run-up to
filter out some of the more um
what should we say avoidable aspects of
going to committee
and get the numbers down i mean i i was
in
one earlier in the year well before
coving but it all we had to do
was agree beforehand with the applicant
of where a shed had got to go and it
would never have ended up in committee
so i just wondered if there's not some
things we could do
to get to filter out some of these
things so that the list wasn't longer
but i agree with the with the quorum uh
suggestion
thank you council rock i think um my
recollection on that one
is that the opportunity to request a
committee hearing
was only for those applications which
would have gone to committee anyway
but which the um officer was
recommending refusal
uh and therefore um by going back the
officer
the applicant might have been concerned
that they would have the same
um uh the same impact as the original
officer proposal
so it wasn't anybody that can apply for
the application
uh to go to committee it was any off and
so there are specific circumstances
where there was a difference of opinion
between the officer and the applicant
um sorry the officer and the board
member of the parish council
which would therefore result in
committee anyway uh
okay um you wish to speak
yes please thank you mr chairman see um
catch the rock was uh proposing to
reduce
a shed load of work there so uh thank
you for that cancel the rock
um yeah i've been in discussions with
uh officers and the portfolio hold down
the other
uh chair um i was chairing the four hour
planning
meeting so i know firsthand i've still
got the scars and i think i've raised
about four years after
after that um i did write to catch the
junior
afterwards thanking her for a positive
and succinct
contributions during that and again i
think we should
should look um all ourselves closely to
how we can
can do this um and and councillor wally
hoggins and and i
and the officers and uh cancer candle uh
i've come up with some proposals that
will
definitely show on the process um and
and definitely
because i can't go through four hours
again like that um so
all in favor of this on the temporary
basis and it's for sensible reasons
there's no hidden agenda and i think um
i'm happy to support this um and
support the portfolio officer uh holder
sorry sarah um uh were there any
proposals on this so
thank you thank you councillor crump
our council wayne hogan's you're coming
back his portfolio holder up on this i
assume
um because of its uh uh normal
procedures you can only speak once but
portfolio holding can come back yes
i wanted to clarify
clarify just clarify some of the points
because the the the raising the fact
that it's not just down to
the uh the quorum is why it's here today
but the proposals are
that um the papers will be out a week
beforehand
there will be rigorous checking that
papers have been read questions will
need to be submitted in advance there
are many many things there
in order to stop these four-hour mammoth
sessions
from from continuing because um you know
it is unacceptable for both those
sitting on the committee
and the um and the officers indeed
to to have to to go to go through that
so
the list of proposals coming out
committee members i can assure you all
that everything is designed in order to
make this a much
slicker process without without
minimizing um the the debate
aspect of it thank you thank you
councillor willie hoggins um
cancer fielding
just a quick quick uh comment on um
counselor crumps scars
um i get back to my comment which i made
to the leader
there's a lot of information we were
arguing around which is all on file
if we'd bothered to look or the planners
had taken up the correspondence
with the our culturalist
um she had answered the questions okay
which we we then argued around
so thank you thank you um
i don't think anybody who has raised any
objections to the proposal
uh urgent business um
so um before we move to the vote i'm
going to invite
uh councillor jefferson uh to speak uh
and then i suggest we move straight to
the vote
um conducted by mr buckland but mr jeff
it comes to justin can i propose we
accept the recommendations that with
immediate if their council agrees to
amend committee procedure rule eight two
to read
the quorum from meeting of the planning
committee should be three members
and two and then paragraph three of the
planning committee
terms of reference to state that each
committee shall comprise nine members
with a quorum of three members
thank you um please can i have a second
or i think um council willy hogan says
um
first in the list that's the willie
hoggins can you confirm orderly that
you're seconding this motion counselor
wally hopkins second in this
this this this proposal thank you thank
you very much indeed we therefore have a
friend for the second of this motion um
and
uh hopefully for the last time today mr
buckland
would you like to run through the roll
call
on this uh proposal please thank you
very much um
chairman of council councillor kettle uh
councillor capital four
councillor dixon councillor dixon four
thank you i believe castle alcock has
left the meeting so um councillor barker
councillor barker four
council cargill four thank you
councillor cleve
councillor cleve four thank you
councillor crumb
crump
counselor fitter for thank you
bill fleming oh sorry uh yeah casual
fleming for
thank you
thank you jenny councillor jennifer
actually
four thank you professor harris
councillor harris four
thank you councillor harvey councillor
harvey four
thank you councillor seraphine
chancellor ancient
thank you jefferson councillor jefferson
for thank you councillor jennings
councillor jennings sport
thank you councillor junaid councillor
junaid four
thank you uh councillor mills council
meals for
thank you castle o'donnell council
o'donnell
for thank you castle parry councillor
parry for
thank you pemberton
richards councillor richards iv
thank you castle riley council and riley
against
okay thank you mr rock councillor rock
four thank you a castle of golf has now
left the meeting so councillor shenton
councillor shenton four thank you
out wally hoggins councillor wally
hoggins
four thank you chairman i'll make that
29 votes for
with one vote against and therefore
there harry thank you
uh thank you mr buckland very much um
there are therefore no
other items on the agenda i would
however like to thank
um all councillors and um
uh all officers supporting us um
for their forbearance for quite a
challenging start
to our first virtual meeting um and it
is disappointing that the
um i think the probably the
broadband infrastructure in south
warwickshire has left the star rather
than the
technology we've had here in stratford
with people losing the image
however i'm convinced that everybody did
hear
the vast majority of all the um
goings on today so um thank you for your
forbearance it's been quite a long
meeting
um and therefore um uh
thank you everybody and i'd also like to
thank caroline nash and elizabelski
who've been bolstering the chairman
today um
so at that point i will declare the
meeting closed and um
we'll look forward to seeing you shortly
i am told that we will be
um holding the annual meeting of the
council
at some point in september that the
chief executive will start
those days too shortly thank you very
much and we'll speak to you soon
thank you